I'm in Baltimore and my voiceover will
now explain why protesting gun violence
is the newest team fad its Bieber fever
but somehow worse and his craze has
spread from Florida to Baltimore
yesterday the mayor of Baltimore
Maryland announced the city will help
students and get to the March for our
lives we're taking 60 buses your job is
the mayor of Baltimore to assist student
athletes are you doing that for the
market ever live anywhere without
liberal adults pushing this agenda
children would never ask for
unreasonable things like gun control and
to not die so I'm sitting down with one
of the kids puppet-masters
Baltimore's mayor pew when you offered
to provide those buses you then funneled
city money into that project didn't you
madam mayor I did not funnel city money
you've shoveled it then
no I didn't made it rain I made it rain
city funds let me just say we didn't
have to use city funds private dollars
have poured in to make sure that these
young people who want to go can go okay
they took the initiative to come to City
Hall to say you know enough is enough I
thought it was great to go out and meet
them and say you know I understand your
pain so they took the initiative to come
to City Hall and make their voices heard
and you want to reward that instead of
listening to the people of Baltimore
madam mayor should be focusing on my
vague understanding of urban crime
Baltimore has some of the most
restrictive gun laws in the country but
lots of gun violence in Baltimore City
there's not a gun shop so they're not
coming from Baltimore City
they are coming into Baltimore City from
other jurisdictions from other states
around the country who have laws that
are less than us aren't you just
teaching them to protest and of course
when I say protest I said with a sneer I
see that I don't think you should sneer
about that protest I know it frightens
you but I think you should go listen to
young people I think that when you go
out there and you have a real
conversation with young people I think
it may shape you I'm not gonna let this
mayor influence me so I've independently
decided to do exactly what she said
I'm swearing off with some students who
are planning to protest gun violence
simply because they've lost classmates
to gun violence thank you for joining me
here at school you may refer to me as
dr. Kobe or professor Kobe or if you
care about accreditation Kobe is
technically okay - all right
youths who's pressuring you to go to
this March nobody have a first name or
know nobody as in nobody no person is
pressuring me to go to the March was
pressuring me to go to the marches
what's happening in our communities
meelo is a kids so in the last decade no
lady is so disbelieving or seven last
year one this year and that's just the
deaf people get shot from our school
every day rabbit it's like if if I don't
hear about gun violence did it happen
that's like saying if you don't hear a
tree fall did it fall exactly yeah
happen oh that is that the answer to
that problem yes yeah like you're
getting them to it and the kids are like
they normalize homicides I don't go
outside I stay in the house oh if I'm
mad at work or school I mean I I just
don't understand why I haven't heard
about this vile it's right I mean these
mass shootings are all over the news
eight students from a school in a single
year why haven't I heard about that
because we black and all eight of the
students are black and it's in a
Baltimore City school yeah I don't
typically come with a neighborhood like
this so the media pays more attention to
gun violence in affluent white
communities I'd use this to talk them
out of marching but it seems the kids
have already considered that first I
wasn't like supportive of the movement I
feel like it was gonna be pointless
I have witnessed shootings and we
haven't had no marches like we haven't
had nobody stand up fuss when you come
from Baltimore and you feel like you're
expressing yourself you don't always
feel like you're being hurt because of
where you're from we're not roots we
don't know people who are in the House
of Representatives that I've running for
City Council are running for mayor we
don't know these people so if your
communities are so different why do you
just let them have their March and you
guys do something else amazing that we
never gonna be heard on the national
level it's bigger than just them you
know it's us together and I feel like
Donna Marshall surprised so many people
like oh my god the youth is coming
together like wow
no this way I'm just saying the
conversation should be separate parkland
can have their conversation you guys can
have your conversation that way they
won't amplify why can't we just all come
together well then it'll be louder and
just more chaotic and more persuasive
and and just me worst and that's the
problem
you don't want change you don't want to
see us succeed you don't want us to
surpass adversity you don't want us to
become greater than our circumstances
and that's the issue
we need people who are willing to
support us and ensure that our future is
a priority for them because we need this
we need this much of our lives in order
to for people like you to understand
that we matter our voices matter black
lives matter
let's analyze matter everybody lies
matter we don't need people like you you
know someday you'll get old and you know
you'll be gone and we'll be able to take
over you have a bully about it while
movements like this have historically
excluded these kids they've decided to
look past that and come together in the
name of collective action so in the face
of this terrifying unity I'll make one
last plea for them to stop mindlessly
repeating adults repeat after me think
for yourself okay then
[Music]